(audience applauding)
- Well, your son recently
graduated from USC.
- Yeah.
Was that crazy for you?
Were you,
- That was crazy.
(audience sympathizing)
- were you just a mess?
- Well.
(Lisa laughing)
Oh yeah.
- I mean, I have a five year old boy,
and I'm just like, this moment, like,
- Oh yeah.
do you think back when he was
(Lisa exclaiming)
five and you're just like,
he's so, he's a man.
- I did then, but I'm telling you,
leading up to his graduation, I was like,
'cause my own graduation from college,
I was like, "That's just a
ceremony" and "Who cares?"
And, "Oh my God, do we
really have to get up early?
What? Uh, we've been up
all night celebrating."
So, when I heard that his was like,
really early in the morning and I said,
"So, are any of you going?"
(Lisa and Kelly laughing)
And he said,
"Yeah, we're all going".
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Weird question.
- Like, "What's wrong with you?"
And I said, "Oh, well, no, of course.
And I'm gonna be there too, yeah."
(audience laughing)
- So excited.
- I was like, "Wow, they
really care. That's great."
(Kelly laughing)
And then I get there and I'm a wreck.
I'm taking pictures.
I'm getting the pictures of the moment
they call his name, and you know,
- Yeah.
just, I was, I went nuts,
and it stayed with me
for a week afterward.
I can't believe how dumb I am.
And I was like, "Well, I mean,
you're not gonna care. Are you?"
- Oh my God,
- What?
I will be the one weeping,
and pictures,
- Yeah.
- and embarrassing my children.
- And I was. And then look,
- Yeah.
- it was like, "I love you so much.
I can't believe you graduated.
I'm so happy."
(both laughing)
- Oh, that's so awesome. I love that.
Wait, I think that Courtney Cox said
at one point that you're very competitive.
- Oh, well.
- I'm very competitive.
Is this true?
- Yeah.
- I am too.
- But intense.
- Very intense.
- I mean it's, I think there's a fine line
between intense and competitive.
- That's what people say to me as well,
but somehow the line gets blurred.
- It gets blurred.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, I guess.
I mean, it's not like I'll,
I'll be mean,
or try to sabotage anyone.
- No, no.
- I really, I would never
- No, I don't wanna cheat.
- No.
- Cheating?
- I can't stand people that-
- That's not a win.
- No, it's not a win.
- It's not a win.
- Doesn't count.
(Kelly gasping)
We oughta play a game next time.
- Yeah, how about it.
- Okay okay,
'cause I love games.
Okay. Okay.
- Yeah.
- Well the first trip that you took,
um, as a cast was,
- Yeah,
- um, was that, was that for Friends?
That was in Vegas?
- Yes.
- Y'all gambled?
- Well, yeah.
- Okay.
- I mean to me, we went
to Vegas to gamble.
I think to everyone else,
we went to connect, but um.
(Kelly laughing)
'cause I get, intense.
- You were like blank check.
- Yeah. Intense, about gambling.
It's like, "Well we're gonna go eat."
"Eat? Why would you spend,
waste time eating when
I can still be playing and winning?"
- Yeah.
- I love you.
- Okay. You are very competitive.
- Yeah.
- Was it a fun trip though?
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause y'all didn't know at the time,
- No, we didn't know.
- that it was gonna blow up.
- No, we hadn't, we hadn't.
it hadn't been on the air yet,
and Jim Burrows got Warner Brothers.
It was the most
unbelievably exciting thing
to give him the private jet.
- Yeah.
- And take just the six of us,
no boyfriends, spouses, or anything,
and go to Las Vegas.
And he took us to dinner at Spago.
- Wow.
- And he said,
- Fancy.
- "You need to be aware,
that at this moment, right now,
the six of you are together at dinner,
after this show airs,
you won't be able to do this anymore."
(audience exclaiming)
- Oh, he knew.
- I guess he did.
- Yeah.
- And everyone else was like, "Wow."
And I thought, "Well, who knows? I mean."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I mean, it's a toss up.
- I know.
Look at me. What does Jim Burrows know?
(Kelly clapping)
(Kelly and audience laughing)
I've always been fun like that.
- Wait, that was me on
American Idol though.
Everybody was like, "This
show's gonna be all like."
They gave us money.
They dropped us off at a mall,
and they gave us money
to like, buy clothes,
to wear on television.
And I was like,
(Kelly laughs)
"I got bills to pay."
(Lisa and audience laughing)
I was like, I like, wore my own clothes.
I was like, "This show's going nowhere."
I'm just like, "Hopefully I can get a job
somehow singing somewhere."
I was the same way.
I think when you think like that,
it's better though. You don't,
you know, you don't.
- Yeah, Yeah.
- Your expectations
are managed.
- Keep them low.
- Yeah. They are.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Keep them low.